je suis
cinquante deux bonnes heures
ces finales elle a quand même une vie
privée assez compliqué sa mère est
atteinte de la maladie d'alzheimer sa
fiancé s'appelle nadine alors concernant
votre mère c'est autobiographique
pendant qu'elle était malade vous êtes
parti pendant un an à son chevet dans
l'appartement de votre enfance à
saint-etienne est pas possible de vous
deux vous décollez d'elle qua non non
parce que quand on sent quand on sait
par cette maladie on ne sait pas que ça
va faire mourir donc c'est pas son reste
parce qu'on sent que mais cette maladie
en tout cas ce fait qu'il ya lâcher
prise de la part des gens qui l'ont eu
ma mère qui était plutôt quelqu'un de du
enfin le voilà qui était en train pudeur
et dureté avait lâché donc elle était
aimante et c'est tout ce qu'on a envie
de le prendre
et puis tiens
une phrase terrible et on perd la
personne mais elle est encore vivant oui
c'est terrible c'est terrible les mots
pour expliquer ça parce que c'est vrai
qu'on devrait les plus là on aurait un
deuil et là on se dit tous les matins on
serait aussi dit je vais faire comme
cheval je vais faire un petit retour
arrière et puis ça va marcher parce que
parce que parfois ça marche donc tac est
clair pourquoi ça marche mais parfois ça
marche l'air depuis un moment il y en a
plus du tout il y en a plus du tout
quand non le jour où ma mère m'a dit tu
sais où muriel ouais je sais que j'ai
vécu une chose que j'entendais cette
expression le sens qu'ils glace j'avais
des connaissances
j'ai eu le 110 c'est glacé d'un truc bon
voilà donc qui après il n'y a plus
jamais ça connectait plus est la
personne n'est plus là et plus alors
voilà le plus là alors à l'issue de
cette aventure tragique vous avez connu
une dépression assez grave
oui oui j'étais très mal quoi j'avais un
peu fait un moment j'étais les yeux au
plafond
je ne sortirai pas quoi oui même à
madras en inde il faut la mettre une
clinique psychiatrique fonds peut pas
laisser comme ça je ça marchait plus que
j'étais plus donc on a misé au bon
endroit
vous avez fait ma terminale donc
souvenirs souvenirs peu importe et puis
voilà il ya des gens dont c'est le
métier
les psys tout simplement des choses
bêtes comme vous forcer à prendre une
douche en dix ans avec de l'eau chaude
parce que ça active le sens et ça voilà
des gens des mots mais surtout ça et
après avoir vu un mois et demi de tennis
sic et rick gg mais j'étais debout voilà
on vous a proposé d'écrire un livre à ce
moment là oui après peu après j'ai
commencé à mettre des mots sur ça je les
ennemis d'ailleurs et et
et je dirais que c'est intéressant dans
cette écriture parce que ta bonne
écriture peut-être s'ils voient quelque
chose à dire d'intéressant c'est quand y
en a plus du tout sans surcoût cent sûr
tant qu'il ya quelque chose qui sortait
comme ça donc j'ai pu balancer 40 pages
qui sont je crois qu'un moment c'est ni
bien ni pas bien quand c'est vrai c'est
vrai que c'est comme si le sait comme je
regardais le coeur et qu'on en dise est
dedans et puis ça m'a fait aller mieux
aussi ça et un moment c'est drôle parce
que je devais les mieux et puis j'ai
voulu écrire puisse commencer à regarder
ce que j'écrivais un récent c'est hélas
j'ai pu écrire ce que je disais non
l'adjectif est allé voir enfin que ce
bouquin si vous êtes servi de thérapie
parce que vite la scène n'est pas du
tout une thérapie pour monter sur scène
il faut aller bien c'est la plus
magnifique des pommades parce que pas
mal quand on a beau beau ça fait ça
c'est nous quoi s'est dit bien mais ça
ne guérit pas ne soigne pas non plus nos
thérapies aussi c'est que vous êtes
délesté de 15 kilos quand même non non
facettes racing avec ce poids alors
après on peut dire des chiffres qu'ils
foutent peut-être il est monté très haut
là vous êtes monté à 94 quand même mais
c'est fait c'est pire moment six kilos
de la centaine mais c'est bien parce que
j'avais beaucoup oui j'avais des ça
faisait pas rire tous mes amis
d'ailleurs le procès de transe mon
attachée de presse du congrès ont fait
une belle fête parce que à la fin de
l'année on va fêter le quintal et ça la
faisait pas rire les gens que j'aime
beaucoup mais paris c'est pas moi c'est
qu'une loi j'étais super bien d'eau les
effets 60 kg jusqu'à 35 ans j'avais un
corps nickel et puis c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas moins ils représentent ce qui
n'est pas à moi dedans quand j'enlève
j'enlève j'enlève ils vont partir avec
quand vous parlez de vous à l'époque ya
quelques années sur scène ou d'y jeter
engoncés dans des vêtements trop serrés
j'avais la tête qui dépasse et avec la
coupe la plus courte possible
espèce de machine de guerre quoi
qu'est-ce que c'est ce visage carré
social cours cette fille est comme ça
qu'est kenny jolies pages avis qu'est ce
que c'est que ce tribunal anglais un
boulot à faire aujourd'hui j'ai un peu
bosser
on vous a connu vous êtes vous êtes
délester aussi de beaucoup de choses
vous aviez des pièces en pics et des
amplis gleave rempli de fringues
brest 10 objets mais disent obligés
d'exiger que j'ai chez moi
n'hésitez pas très diplôme quand même
les disques des jeux c'est pourquoi ils
sont là ils ont un sens donc c'est pas
mal et l'appartement où il avait vendu
il ya un an mais on vend ce qu'à un
moment vous disiez tant pis j'irai
habiter chez line renaud aussi avec
n'importe où ou si je me suis dit ça dit
non même à qui tu as la peau il était
autour de la pâte à saint germain
sixième avant la même m² à 150 me
répondait que c'était important 550 m²
va gagner oui c'est vrai mais il dit lui
que tous les deux c'est très gentil pour
la joue depuis ce que tu as dit maudit
vous êtes toujours évolué vous étiez
parfait tous les deux donc je ne sais
pas sûrement mois à la sa coupe et donc
son carnet de mètres carrés maurienne et
tu le vends combien je vends le prix que
coûte c'est à dire 2 millions d'euros 2
millions d'euros donc quitté cat
intéressé sait quelle heureuse je suis
sûr que les gens riches qui regarde bien
sûr série chérie 1,81 dans le 6e des
push push se mettre à plusieurs
après un énorme et donc 2 millions mais
tu sais négociable ou pas deux millions
c'est ce que ça coule donc voilà deux
millions met à douter rallonge cheminée
vous enlevez tout s'éclaire ces 2009 et
ce bruit on sait surtout suivant sa
maison mais charge pas trop de charges
et bénéfices de ta pièce tu sais ce
qu'ils te faire y a plus qu'à attendre
petite vingtaine d'années machete la
partie bien alors dans au secours lisa
l'héroïne est bisexuelle et sa lancée
passé comme une lettre à la poste sur
les gens que vous avez dit ça sur celle
bullet ma fiancée s'appelle nadine gelas
pas choquer les gens pas sauter en l'air
non alors moi je vais être vraiment
honnête c'est que quand un moment quand
il fallait que cette fille ou une fois
qu'on avait fait rentrer la mère celle
là ça il fallait bien qu'elle ait la vie
privée et la plus pire n'était plus avec
moi jusqu'au moment il n'a plus pu
écrire avec mal an j'étais seul je me
suis dit bon évidemment les quelques un
mec et j'étais avec roger louret au
metteur en scène et je lui dis c'était
qu'il fallait ce que c'est pas plus
drôle plus drôle surtout dans la fiction
après savoir si lisa c'est comme moi on
peut se poser la question
je faisais la question moi je vous la
poserai pas parce que comme vous savez
je suis discrétion légendaire vrac tout
le monde le sait dans ce pays désormais
évident a dit voir certaines émissions
d'une pudeur ne l'imposé pas je ne le
faisais pas et j'apprécie ce que ça fait
plusieurs fois que je viens
c'est plusieurs fois par soir sur les
terrains vous êtes les gens sont mal à
l'aise mais puisque vous me l'imposé pas
je vous réponds que c'est que je prends
l'amour là où il est l'allié très courte
j'imagine que pour vous les êtres
humains l'être humain est plus important
que le 7 c'est bien pourquoi
ceci étant je vais déclarer je sait
depuis toujours que je finirais ma vie
avec un homme
oui j'ai dit sage et bien c'est pas bien
parce que c'est déjà encore me foutent
rien je sais rien je sais rien je suis
je sais rien je sais rien je sais rien
mais donc au secours est un gros succès
le dvd va cartonner et pourtant
récemment on vous a beaucoup entendu
vous vous plaindre dans les médias de ce
que personne vous propose deux films au
cinéma
vous dites on ne désire pas pourquoi
qu'est-ce que j'ai qui leur déplaît à
meilleur là est-ce que je suis trop
blonde est ce que je suis trop gros c
est ce que j'ai le menton trop trop
carré parce que quand on est populaire
c'est une constatation est un bonheur
mais depuis maintenant plus de quinze
ans l'une des plus populaires peuvent
être jugés dans la vérité et c'est vrai
je n'ai pas de proposition mais pas un
point qui fait qu'au début on dit bon
ben c'est pas grave
et puis dernièrement au début puis après
ou si on dit c'est pas grave est
plausible on est depuis ce qu'on a de
l'orgueil donc on dit fixation vol pas
de moi mais de ça tombe bien puisque
toute façon moi non plus je veux pas
d'eux finit par se trouver voilà et puis
et puis on peut aussi un moment
s'arrêter puis se dire je
si j'enlève l'orgueil moi je me suis dit
si tu enlèves l'orgueil muriel qu'est ce
que ça fait et j'ai pleuré et j'ai
pleuré mais vraiment ce que je vous dis
à ce point là rien à me proposer
pourquoi du pile dans ta pas écris ton
truc sur me donne envie d autres si vous
désirez et je vais déjà me mettre des
gens à dos si je veux en faire un vus
parfois ce que je peux voir je pense que
je peux en écrire un par mois à la
passion c'est le problème de faire un
film c'est le désir que vous avez
d'autres façons de regarder les gens ne
savent pas mais peut-être que j'aurais
dû plus le dire mais j'ai fait le
conservatoire je pense que je vais avoir
un parcours comédienne qui se trouve que
j'avais appris et michel bouquet oui je
suis moi je sais pas je fais du mois de
match mais jamais de ma vie je sais ça
et je trouve que je le fais plus que ça
ma façon c'était ça ou rien vu 15 ans et
vous avez reçu que des scénarios vous
dites avec des rôles pitoyable de
camionneuse qui jure équipe est enfin
pas des trucs y revint scénario appels
entrants et un truc mais donc encore une
fois je suis dans la vérité je dis que
ça me fait de la peine
je dis clairement je dis que je veux
bien je dis encore d'autant plus je le
mien d'autant plus que le one man show
celui là était différent le prochain jeu
le même pas sur le rhin et c'est vrai
que si je suis désirer dans ce métier je
suis sûr que même mâchoire deviendront
un peu plus voilà un peu plus
triangulaire et que je dirais super en
ce moment ça va bien et qu'on dira tiens
ses deux fils et elle va bien quand elle
est sympa et la carapace ne vient pas de
rien parce que ça dit quoi d'être désiré
c'est un moment une famille mais pas
papa d'une famille de cinq six personnes
mais la famille de ce métier voilà c'est
qu'ils aient envie qu'ils me prennent
dans leurs bras
avant c'est bon je moi je j'ai fait ce
métier c'est qu'on l'ait vraiment
l'aimer mais motivation mais je le
disais un jour salade pulmonaire on va
le donner moi ils vont tous me regarde
et puis je vais leur dire merci vous
être ma famille puis je vous dis merci
suite grâce à vous j'ai aidé à vivre
et puis j'arrive jamais jamais donc
jeudi une famille parce que pas de
parents d'enfants de familles dont le
nom mais voyez ce que j'ai dis donc
bon ben si ça doit être comme ça ça ira
et surtout très important mais vraiment
c'est pas une plainte
c'est juste que j'ai le droit de dire ça
aussi même si j'ai vécu c'est pendant
ces quinze ans beaucoup de beaucoup de
bobos si j'ai reçu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'amour et comment que ce
public parce que il a été tellement là
est que
ça m'a aidé a tonné aussi seul